good morning everyone welcome to better
than food book reviews I dreamed myself
here have any of you out there tried
this Transcendental Meditation stuff I'm
not going to be like a David Lynch
proponent it's really great but you know
that actually is a pretty effective tool
for your
box
so feeling pretty good very calm very
nice day outside who on Earth reviews
this in sunny weather me that's
who what a book
so one of the nice things about having
this channel is that
um not only do
I give book recommendations to change
people's lives but other people change
my life with their wonderful insightful
recommendations and uh this is just a
gem this is a hell of a book I don't
know how to navigate this review
you I have no idea where to begin
although pesoa would probably say that
uh beginning is giving up so here I go
in into the abyss of an action except
not except maybe I'll never fully
process it and I don't know if I I would
want to this is easily one of the most
incredible unbelievable books I've ever
read and the story seems the story
behind it seems like pure fiction and
many people along the way of this
channel have recommended the book of dis
quiet and uh forgive me though I I don't
know who first recommended it and I
can't sift through all the comments but
um you know certainly this is for all
the friends out there in Portugal I've
spent quite a bit of time in Lisbon
wonderful City if you've never been
ahead and put it on the top of your list
beautiful place wonderful people
incredible food very historic Al
interesting
and mysterious
architecture all around Lisbon and Old
Lisbon but also in some small towns out
towards the coast
CRA was my favorite place in the world
that was where uh Lord Byron was kicking
around drinking Ginga Jinga Ginga ging
and uh writing uh writing
poetry and it's a little town on the
side of a mountain mountain with a
Moorish Castle on top and it's all these
decaying chat and lot of old overgrowth
everywhere trees everywhere
and beautiful
women but no follow
portuges got to get on that Fernando
pesoa was a Portuguese author and poet
born in 1888 he spent much of his time
in Lisbon before passing away at the
young age of 47 while he was widely
considered one of the greatest
poets in Portuguese history he also
spoke and wrote quite fluently in French
and English he was famous for writing
through heteronyms and this is actually
a term that pooa created because he
thought that pseudonym was too reductive
and simplistic heteronym is an entirely
different
fictional
author and he had close to 80 of these
heteronyms constructed ever since he was
a kid he started when he was like six
and he just constructed these
personalities and these points of view
often extremely different from one
another the book of dis quiet was not
published while PESA was alive in fact
far far after he had passed away this
was quite
literally locked in a
trunk and found after he had passed away
along
with an almost nauseating amount of work
that aidun not is still being edited to
this day this is a man who wrote in
almost total obscurity he published a
few books while he was alive but this
was a real life of the Mind modus
operandi an introvert to conquer all
introverts it's speculated he was a
lifelong virgin and he's quite possibly
the most articulated
sufferer of ab abysmally depressive
loneliness and an absolute Flatout
indispensable
genius I love to be surprised when as
though I've wrenched all the nourishment
from the wet towel of fiction and then
all of a sudden I'm covered in a
torrential cascading flood of original
Pros so distinctively unique it's
aggravating to realize that you'll never
write anything
that good well you might but I probably
will not writing from all these
different heteronyms the book of diset
is sort of structured like a diary into
481 entries of all these different
characters all ranging from several
pages to just a few words I have so many
dog ears in this book that uh I have so
many dog ear pages in this book that I
almost want to start back at the
beginning again if it weren't for some
of the truly devastating passages of
contradictory desire for lack of
Desiring and heralding of total
inaction yeah pesoa is an absolute and
total contradiction at least you know
the way he's portrayed in this book got
a little bit of sun there had to cool
down a little bit there we go a man who
may have known that people were the most
important thing in life and yet if he
did know that he willfully ignored it
and chose the opposite route he
preferred to dream his life as opposed
to to living it I've never done anything
but dream this and this alone has been
the meaning of my life my only real
concern has been my inner life my worst
Sorrows have evaporated when I have
opened the window onto the street of my
dreams and forgotten myself in what I
saw
there I've never aspired to be more than
a dreamer I paid no attention to those
who spoke to me of living I've always
belonged to to what isn't where I am and
to what I could never be whatever isn't
mine no matter how base has always had
poetry for me the only thing I've Loved
is nothing at all the only thing I've
desired is what I couldn't even imagine
am man I want to read more but we got
keep going this is a man who so
desperately craved love or the want to
want to want to
love or to want love after losing so
many people in his life from a young age
to his father died died when he was
young his mother died later on he always
had this sort
of persona of being a stranger the only
attitude worthy of a superior man is to
persist in an activity he recognizes is
useless to observe a discipline he knows
is sterile and to apply certain Norms of
philosophical and metaphysical thought
that he considers utterly
inconsequential a boresi disciple of the
highest degree going through Joyce TS
Elliott Milton Shakespeare everyone yet
relatively simple to read or perhaps so
brilliantly constructed that it only
seems simple in its execution I'm handed
Faith Like a sealed package on a strange
looking platter and am expected to
accept it without opening it I'm handed
science like a knife on a plate to cut
the folios of a book whose pages are
blank I'm handed doubt like dust inside
a box why give me a box if all it
contains is
dust no intelligent idea can gain
General acceptance unless some stupidity
is mixed in with it Collective thought
is stupid because it's Collective
nothing passes into the realm of the
collective without leaving at the border
like a toll most of the intelligence it
contained in youth we twofold our innate
intelligence which may be considerable
coexists with the stupidity of our
inexperience which forms a second less
intelligence only later only later on do
the two unite that's why youth always
blunders not because of its inexperience
but because of its non-unity today the
only course left for the man of superior
intelligence is abdication sometimes
he'll start somewhere and then he'll
just contradict himself like two or
three times over by the end of the whole
like paragraph occasionally but it never
seems like he's lying even though what
he says may not be true and trust me I'm
not spoiling any of this for you I mean
you're going to find so many of these
that you love there's almost 500 of
these so I mean you have so much to
discover that I could not possibly spoil
the book of dis quiet for you we never
love anyone what we love is the idea we
have of someone it's our own concept our
own selves that we love this is true in
the whole gamut of love in sexual love
we seek our own pleasure via another
body in nonsexual love we seek our own
pleasure via our own idea the
masturbator may be object but in point
of fact he's a perfect logical
expression of the lover he's the only
one who doesn't Fain and doesn't fool
himself the relations between one soul
and another expressed through such
uncertain and variable things as shared
words and proferred gestures are
deceptively complex the very Act of
meeting each other is a non-meeting two
people say I love you or mutually think
it and feel it and each has in a mind
and each has in mind a different idea a
different life perhaps even a different
color or fragrance in the abstract sum
of Impressions that constitute the
Soul's activity today I'm Lucid as if I
didn't exist my thinking is as naked as
a skeleton without the fleshly tatters
of the illusion of expression and these
considerations that I forg and abandon
weren't born from anything at least not
from anything in the front rows of my
Consciousness perhaps it was the sales
representative's disillusion with his
girlfriend perhaps a sentence I read in
one the Romantic tales that our
newspapers reprint from the Foreign
Press or perhaps just a vague nausea for
which I can think of no physical cause
the scist who annotated Virgil was wrong
understanding is what wearies US most of
all to live is to not
think and he's also certainly not
without a sense of humor for example
read the chapter on indifference or
something like that as it's titled the
superior man differs from the inferior
man and his Animal Brothers by the
simple trait of irony irony is the first
sign that our Consciousness has become
conscious and it passes through two
stages the one represented by Socrates
when he says all I know is that I know
nothing and the other represented by
Sanchez when he says I don't even know
if I know nothing and throughout it he
rejects almost everything he even
rejects as I'm sure a lot of people are
ready to label this pessimism he even
rejects
pessimism in a very simple and poignant
manner we ch I will gladly read you
now I don't complain about the world I
don't protest in the name of the
universe I'm not a pessimist I suffer
and complain but I don't know if
suffering is the norm nor do I know if
it's human to suffer why should I care
to know I suffer without knowing if I
deserve to I'm not a pessimist I'm sad
to read is to dream Guided by someone
else's hand to read carelessly and
distractedly is to let go of that hand
to be only superficially learned is the
best way to read well and be profound
how shoddy and contemptible life is note
that for it to be shoddy and
contemptible all it takes is you not
wanting it it being given to you anyway
and nothing about it depending on your
will or even on your illusion of your
will to die is to become completely
other that's why suicide is a
cowardice it's to surrender ourselves
completely to life
whatever we pursue we pursue for the
sake of an ambition but either we never
realize the ambition and we are poor or
we think we've realized it and we're
rich fools peso was trunk Pandora's
Box The unrecognized Genius of a dead
Portuguese
master in an even stranger and
infinitely disturbing
passage that will has kept me up a
little bit uh
he was his own
Prophet what does that mean it sometimes
occurs to me with sad Delight that if
one day in a future to which I won't
belong the sentences I write are read
and admired then at last I'll have my
own kin people who understand me my true
family in which to be born and loved but
far from being born into it I'll have
already died long ago
I'll be understood only in effigy when
affection can no longer compensate for
the indifference that was the Dead Man's
lot in life perhaps one day they'll
understand that I fulfilled like no one
else my instinctive duty to interpret a
portion of our century and when they've
understood that they'll write that in my
time I was misunderstood that the people
around me were unfortunately indifferent
and insensitive to my work and that it
was a Pity this happened to me and
whoever writes this will fail to
understand my literary counterpart in
the future time just as my contemporary
don't understand me because men learn
only what would be of use to their
great-grandparents the right way to live
is something we can teach only the
[Music]
dead and that totally
happened they found his book and they
just couldn't help themselves
and who else knows what this man has
written you know I could read just about
any sentence from this book and get
something incredible out of
it it's not without its difficulties
though you know it could become
increasingly tedious and depressing
reading line after line about TDM and
depression me personally I had to take
some breaks now and then because I would
often find my eyes about five pages
ahead of where my brain was just kind of
glossing over but that's just me
personally some of you kids are going to
pick this [__] up and you're going to
read it in 2 days and then start back at
page one so it's a lamentation on love
dreams art existence possession
expression fulfillment discouragement
interiority exteriority politics
nature life
itself maybe the saddest beautiful book
ever
written and now I've said some much
about it and you probably still have no
idea what the hell I'm talking about I
don't even know what I'm talking about
anymore the review was set up to be a
failure because I've taken action to do
it but maybe that failure is a
success it's a success if you read the
book and start
dreaming yeah start dreaming
so it's absolutely better than food
worth
dreaming please remember what Mr John
Waters said if you go home with someone
and they don't have
books think about why they don't have
books because they might actually be the
next genius author in the next 50 years
after everybody passes away and make
sure that the reason they don't have
books is because they're stupid before
you don't [__] them and not because
they've read so many books that they
just got tired of reading and just had
to write all their own stuff which is
actually locked in a trunk in the corner
of the room check for
Trunks and then give them a hug if they
look like they need
it okay have a great day see you soon
bye